Most traders won't believe what I'm
about to show them. I make an average of
$4,000 trading NQ on just one time frame
and taking only one trade per day for 30
minutes, then I close my laptop. Here we
have five days last week, same setup,
same time, 100% win rate, and 20K in
profits. And also, here are the stats
for the last 3 months. So, I will start
the 7-minute timer, and by the time it
ends, you know exactly where to enter,
where to place your stop loss, where to
place your TP, and how exactly to
execute the strategy to have results
like this. Now, let's go to the charts.
You can see here all the trades that I
took on NQ last week, five out of five
with 100% win rate. Now, let's dive deep
into the strategy. Before doing anything
and before market open, I always always
check my bias for the day. I use my
custom indicator to do that. These are
these three EMAs that you see here.
These are simply the higher time frames
EMA into the 5-minute charts. You can
copy my settings here. I'm using three
EMAs. All of them are 50 EMAs period.
The 15 minutes, the 30 minutes, and the
1-hour time frames. All the big
institutions always keep an eye on these
EMAs. You see how the price respect
them? If these EMAs are stacked and
pointing up, I only look for buys. If
these EMAs are stacked and pointing
down, I'm only looking for sells. If
these EMAs are flat like this, I simply
don't take a trade. This is my entire
bias in only 5 seconds. Now, let's get
to step two. After defining our bias in
step one, we need to see a counter trend
plus an FVG. This day is obviously
bullish. We need to see
a counter trend like this and an FVG
inside a counter trend. Let me play the
candles forward so I can show you the
FVG. We are obviously here bullish using
these three EMAs. Now, we can see an FVG
formed here in a counter trend. That
means we are bullish, but we are pulling
back right now. Let me quickly remove
this.
This is step two. We need to find this
FVG inside the pullback. Now, let's play
the price forward.
And here is the third step. If we
inverse this FVG, that means if the
price breaks through this FVG in the
direction of the trend, that means we go
in, we put our stop loss under the swing
low,
and we target the previous liquidity. If
we have none, we go for 2R, and we trade
the continuation. Let's play this trade
out.
Easy TP.
I promise you, if you simply execute
this strategy every single day, you
don't need 2 years to be profitable with
trading. You just need to master this
exact strategy and forget about all the
you hear from the demo gurus.
Now, let me give you another example. We
can clearly see that the EMAs are
stacked pointing up, so our bias would
be bullish. This is the first step. The
second step is we need to look for a
counter trend and a fair value gap
inside this counter trend. We can
clearly see that we have a fair value
gap here in this counter trend. This is
a pullback  counter trend. We
have an FVG inside it. This is step two.
Now, all we need is for the price to
break this fair value gap. Let's play
the price out.
And here is step three. Price broke the
fair value gap. We go in. We place our
stop loss at this candle,
and we target 2R. Let's play the price
out.
And the TP hit. Easy as that. Make sure
if you have any questions to drop them
in the comments below. I will make sure
to answer every each one of you. Now,
let's go back into another example.
Before I forget something, the counter
trend can happen before or after the
market open. It doesn't matter. As you
can see here on Wednesday, I took a
trade
based on this fair value gap right here.
After market open, I noticed that this
fair value gap wasn't inversed yet.
That's why I did go in, place
[clears throat] my stop loss under the
EMA because after 9:30 candles, price
moved too violently. That's why I placed
my stop loss under the EMA right here,
and I targeted 2R because we don't have
any
previous liquidity here on the left.
This trade was from Wednesday. We can
check it out. This is the trade right
here. These are the trades that I showed
you earlier in the video.
Let's go to the previous day. You can
see here market open is right here. We
can zoom in. We can clearly see a small
counter trend right here, an FVG inside
this counter trend. It was inversed by
this candle. I did go in and targeted 2R
because obviously we don't have a
previous liquidity. This trade was on
Tuesday.
Let's go to Monday.
We can see here market has opened right
here. We are obviously bullish because
price is above the EMAs, and they are
stacked up.
I waited for this counter trend here to
happen. We have a clear fair value gap
inside it. Price broke this fair value
gap. I did go in, placed my stop loss
under this wick right here, and targeted
2R. This was a trade from Monday. You
can clearly see this is a trade from
Monday. This is a trade from Tuesday.
This is a trade from Wednesday. This is
a trade from Thursday, and this is a
trade from Friday. Five back-to-back
trades. Like I always say, no
cherry-picking, no picking just one
trade that looks good one time per
month. I trade this
every single day. But although I had a
100% win rate on this week, I had couple
of losses last week, and here are my
stats for the last 4 months. 75% win
rate. These are my stats for April.
$41,000,
83% win rate, 10 wins and two losses.
And now, let's go to the chart to do a
quick recap. Step one, every single time
you come to the market, you need to
define your bias. If these EMAs are
pointing up, you go long. If these EMAs
are pointing down, you go short. If
these EMAs are flat, you don't trade at
all. Next, you look for a counter trend.
That means if we have a bullish trend,
we look for this pullback right here,
and we look for a fair value gap inside
this pullback. Step one is done. Step
two is done. For the third step, we wait
for the price to invert this fair value
gap. That means price needs to break
this bearish fair value gap that was
created right here. After breakout, you
go in. You put your stop loss under the
swing low or under the previous candle.
You either target previous liquidity or
simply 2R. That's the exact same
strategy I use every single day. That's
the entire setup. I'm only taking one
trade per day on the 5-minute chart and
only following these three steps. I'm
100% sure that every single one can
learn this and be profitable under a
week. If you want to see every trade I
take, wins and losses, make sure to
subscribe, leave a comment down below,
and see you on the next one.